why is it so hard for some people to  recognize faces  is the pterodactyl really a dinosaur and  what does that have to do with ethics  and computing are gmos helpful or  harmful and how do we know is calculus a  language  welcome to chalk radio season three this  season we'll talk with more mit  professors about the passions that fuel  their cutting-edge research and  innovative teaching of topics like  neurocognitive science climate  laboratory chemistry computer science  and many more so tune in to hear candid  funny serious and personal conversations  and as always we'll share links in our  show notes so you can find our guests  open educational resources on mit  opencourseware  chalk radio it's the closest thing to  being here